Ambiance lors d'un dîner avec le Président de la France
le maître des bandits était très
amical
Kazan
a eu lieu après le dîner et le serveur s'est offensé
Je vais nous appeler ici je suis exclusivement
intérêt extrême intéressant et je pense
très serviable et y vit après cela
arriver, nous avons échangé des vues sur un certain nombre de
des questions
il le considère un peu portable 9
entre la France et
ainsi que certains internationaux
problèmes
que la France et
voile et
dans cette partie
conversation avec
L'institut vestimentaire a été très utile et
ce parent
Je vais vous dire tout de suite quoi et à propos de ça
nous étions déjà convaincus de tout ce que nous avons parlé et je
parlait au nom du Soviet
gouvernements avec satisfaction
voyage je suis déjà je me cherche déjà dans ce voyage
instant de remerciement
je suis déjà je suis déjà en retard